today i'm starting with a correction
last week in discussing
a white house press secretary kelly
mcinanny's claim
that the odds of what happened in terms
of the vote in four different states
were one in one quadrillion she also
said
the odds of that happening in four
states
is one in one quadrillion raised to the
fourth power
i with no explanation said that's not
how exponents work
that was very unclear and really
inaccurate in the context in which i
said it
if one and one quadrillion were the
right numbers at the state level
raising it to the fourth power would
give us the combined probability
in theory that is how exponents work by
not explaining
i may have not been clear and i
apologize for that
i will try to do better in the future uh
let's get on to the week's news
it's a truly a tragedy what's going on
in this country
in general but i'm talking right now
about coronavirus
i get that we're a huge country
geographically
we have 330 million people i get that
but we're some of the worst of the worst
in the world
and we are now having a 9 11's worth of
deaths
on one day regularly and the numbers are
potentially going to get
much worse before they get any better
now i know many people on the right
including donald trump like to say well
everyone is seeing the same thing
that could not be further from the truth
and i want to examine that with you
today because we really need to
understand
just how terribly we are doing the claim
is everyone's seeing the same thing
cases are spiking here cases are spiking
there italy
you know sweden whatever that's mostly
based on
this spike in mid-october
that we started seeing just like many
other european countries
but there are two really important
differences to understand here the first
is that when the u.s started seeing its
october spike
that was already our third spike because
we had spike number one in april and
spike number two in july so
middle of october we're on spike number
three
that's a key difference because in italy
for example
their mid-october spike was only their
second spike in other words
italy successfully suppressed the virus
throughout may
june july august september early october
so when we were entering spike 3
and they were also spiking they were
only on their second spike so that's a
huge difference and that applies
to just about all of these european
countries that did not have the second
spike we had
just as importantly these european
countries that started getting a spike
when we did in mid-october
most of them have already suppressed the
spike and they've seen a decline
from the highs of about 50 percent of
new cases per day so as an example
we look at spain and you see that yes
spain
started having spike number two at the
same time that we started having spike
number three
but their trend line for the seven day
case average is already down by half
from where it peaked if you look at
another example like france
you also see that while they spiked in
mid-october like we did
their cases are already way down but
when you look at the united states
we have this spike that started at the
same time but we are reaching new
records just about every day
this has been one of the biggest
failures of any presidential
administration
ever it's globally shameful but it is a
tragedy in terms of its
its toll on human life and suffering and
it's going to take time to fix this now
there's no way around it and and we know
that on january 21st every coronavirus
death will be blamed on joe biden by
these republicans
all i care is that we fix it if now they
want to start wearing masks and social
distancing because biden's present
then do it in order to show i don't know
what i don't think that that's going to
be their reaction and of course
it's too late for the 300 000 people
that died already
it's too late for the many that
recovered from serious cases of the
virus
and still have symptoms and unknown
long-term effects that we don't yet
understand the good news is the fda
has approved an emergency use
authorization for the pfizer biontech
vaccine i've been saying bioentech but
someone told me it's biontech
that is approved and we're going to talk
about vaccination momentarily
december 17th which is uh what is that
thursday
the fda will be meeting about the
moderna vaccine and we'll have a more
detailed report later in the week
about that if indeed it is approved and
we'll talk more about vaccines
momentarily
but this is a cautionary tale about what
not to do
this is not about taking you know it's
so depressing about
don jr early in this entire fiasco
said oh democrats want people to die to
make trump look bad
no i have not i've not found a single
person on the left or a democrat who
wants people to die
uh what we do want is that those
responsible for the failed leadership be
held accountable in a sense trump was
because he lost the election but this is
really a cautionary tale about what not
to do
and part of what not to do is don't
elect a buffoonish and competent clown
to be president of the united states
let's talk about vaccination
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video